one interesting thing that i found so
what i like to do
is i like to find out who um
is buying different parts of real estate
or different real estate so i go to the
realdeal.com and there's this one
segment called yolanda says it's like
this fake author name yolanda he goes i
heard a rumor
that this person's buying a house the
owner is this this and this yolanda
hears that
um they're gonna offer this much money i
have no idea jolan is a fake person
right it's just like a blog a blog
website gossip blog yeah
for real estate mostly in new york and
la though so they're kind of famous
famous e-purse people doing it and what
i love to do is find out who bought
who's buying the real estate
and then i go and research them and the
reason why is one of the best ways to
figure out if someone's actually wealthy
or not
is by the real estate holdings that they
own that's one of the few things that
it's really hard to fake i mean you
could fake it but
if someone has bought a 20 million
dollar home the likelihood
that they're worth 100 million plus is
incredibly high
um you know it's hard to like
that right and so real estate holdings
is one of the best way to get an
indicator of someone's wealth
or it's a great way not the best way but
it's a great way and i found one that
interested me a ton this guy's name was
brian carringer and he uh
bought a house in malibu in 2019 for 20
million dollars i hadn't heard brian
i know a lot of internet entrepreneurs
um
i hadn't heard of them so i researched
them and this is the guy who started
dictionary.com
kind of a crazy thing when you think
about it because who
really thinks of dictionary
dictionary.com so in the 1990s this guy
started uh in 1995 he started a business
called
lexico publishing and lexico publishing
owned
the thesaurus.com and dictionary.com
and he bootstrapped it and he grew and
he sold it in 2005 to iac
for a hundred million dollars and then
uh
two years ago iac sold dictionary.com to
dan gilbert you know dan gilbert quicken
loans yep
he sold dictionary.com for uh or they
sell dictionary.com for a hundred
million dollars so they they didn't do
a very good job with it but
dictionary.com gets around 40
dictionary.com and thesaurus.com gets
around 40 million uniques a month and
does about 20 million in revenue
and they have barely any employees i i
believe dozens of employees
it's incredibly fascinating because this
is the one i call it
how do they make money it's just adsense
or is there something else just ads
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be
what i want to i put my law in it like
no days off
on a road less travel never looking back